it's quite amazing every time in every
sport
when you say it's like the most niche
spot when you go
down in the in the from the professional
to the third fourth league
it's amazing the amount of game they are
played and the
most amazing i think is the youth market
in the us
it's it's it's like a religious
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
sports and technology what a beautiful
intersection i am
joined today by gal oz the cto and
co-founder of pixelot
the world leading company for fully
autonomous video and data production for
sports events
pixar produces a new game around the
globe every 30 seconds
he served for 10 years with an elite r d
unit in the intelligence core of the idf
during which gaul worked with different
visual platforms to capture information
from uav to satellites prior he was the
founding group member of sport vu
and served as the ceo and r d manager of
the company
until it was sold to us-based company
stats in 2008.
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
for joining me thank you for hosting me
i'm really excited to have you with me
today um the founder and cto of pixelot
working on autonomous video and data
production for sports events i believe
that you do a new game every 30 seconds
or so
you've served for more than 10 years in
an r d unit in the idf
previously you were in the founding
group of sport vu and
and you saw it being sold to you to the
us-based company stats in 2008
and i'm curious in this next 20 minutes
to chat with you a little bit about
your personal journey throughout um
throughout you know the sports industry
and why you chose sports tech and what
have you learned
from your different endeavors there and
a little bit also about pixel life so
before we do all that god
tell me a little bit about yourself and
how do you find yourself
in the sports tech industry so
it's a little bit about myself i mean
did it quite maybe we can call it the
usual technician
processing in israel i went there i
finished high school i went to the
atu learning before the army learning
a degree in electrical engineering then
i joined
the
[Music]
the army and served as a actually as an
engineer but
it was quite a fat nature journey i
spent there 10 years eventually
i was working with everything that
regarding videos picture
from a uavs to satellite
to imagery and and i over there i i
i call it i did my first a few startups
in this uh area of the expertise
and then uh during the army i also did
my master's degree in bio mechanical
engineering bio
bio medical engineering specifically in
the in the vision
aspect and i was thinking when i really
leave the army i will save the world
from cancer or something like this
but you know things happened and i found
myself joining uh
dr miki tamir who was already has
this company support you and i joined
him and together we
we built this amazing company that's
doing uh
a tracking of players in real time and
generous statistics
and then i i called it i got into this
bermuda triangular where you have both a
spot which is fascinating
you have television which is amazing and
you have top technology
and since then i really deep inside
uh after spojio
and now i have pixel out which is
exactly more or less the same industry
and really hard to get out of it it's a
amazing
and amazing industry so tell me a little
bit more about this industry
how how how does the integration between
sports and technology actually work
in you know sports at the end you know
conceptually it's a very
low-tech uh type of activity uh
how does one integrates tech with it and
in what regards
so sport eventually you know it's the
atlas in the mid it's the atlas in the
middle
that you about the human spirit but i
think the nice thing is the tech
can surround it and integrate very
nicely so um
with sporjo for example what we did is
is getting a very detailed
uh statistics and analytics about the
game that completely changed the way
uh people analyze nba games and things
like that
uh and it's a improved the way
that the player were playing and
and improve their with the game itself
and pixelate i think it's even more
amazing because what we do is
actually democratize the sport and
and just a few days ago we got a very
for me it was emotional we had a big
project now in africa
and we got a video of you know an
african village
with a tv watching a game that was
produced by pixelot
of their local local team
so their their team never were
was was filmed in tv because nobody
care about it but uh when we have the
pixel system that you can produce
a an event that will cost you only a few
dollars
now it's really democratize the sport
and this is how
which we change the the way people enjoy
sport
but also enjoy improve the way people
all over the world can see the athletes
from africa
so walk me walk me a little bit through
the pain point that you were solving so
so i i have this image in my head of
what you were describing
and it sounds amazing what what is
actually the
what trend does this point to
that that needed pixel art so you know
we all watch sports
you know nba nfl all these sports
so if you take all the registered sport
in the world
like oh not the you and your friends
going to support to to play a
in the local field but but all the sport
has been registered
and less than one percent of the sport
is being televised
and the reason is obvious because
television cost money
bringing the most simple production will
cost you a few thousand of dollars and
and for that you need
tens or hundreds a thousand people
watching it in order to get
a commercial and all this stuff so so
this is the
the traditional market so what pixelate
is after is not the one percent
of the already covered sports but after
the 99
of the nanka uncover sport and we cover
it in the way
which is dramatically lower cost than
before
fully automated very easy to install to
operate
and then suddenly you have like a whole
blue ocean
of content that you can create business
around
because at the end you you will produce
it
if you have a way to to monetize it
sometimes uh it can be
for example we have many teams in
scotland for example that are from the
third league and we have their system
there
and once the cove the epidemic start
they had no way and they went back to
play
but the fans wasn't allowed to join so
these teams all their money were from
fans coming into the venue
but now there are no fans coming in so
they were like almost on a
bankrupt a period but then we built them
an ott platform that you can charge
money for this
and you see amazing places where like a
town of 8 000 people
get 800 people paying to watch
the town uh soccer game and it's bring
them back
more money and they can survive this
this time
and we see it all over it's it's quite
amazing that the revolutionary is due
for the fan experience and for the team
themselves
so what does pixelate actually do how
does pixelot actually enable at the end
for a game to be i understand at the end
that you know the the
big impact that's happening here is that
you're you're basically an enabler
for the 99 of games that weren't
you know featured before on streaming
and television
to do just that right yeah so we give a
basically an end-to-end solution it
starts with our
we have a our call our camera which is
panoramic
so we capture the game in a 180 degree
and we in a very high resolution so
imagine we
we have a super resolution camera that
that cover the whole field in a very
very high resolution
without any moving part out of it we
analyze the game
we know where the ball is where the
player is what is the game state
whether it's now a corner there is a
free kick and and then we decide
we we mimic the camera the human camera
uh cameraman and we decide what is the
best time to take
and this happened 30 frames per second
or 60 frames per second
and this is how we create a movement
that looks like a tv
a great story i mean where we feel good
we tried to create to to make it look
like a real tv
and for example a few days ago i had a
interview candidate for one of the
positions and
his son is playing in a team that
using our system and they charge
money for this but they didn't tell
their parents
uh that this automatic system they told
that
if you want to see that you okay the
your kid's their game because you cannot
come to the game you need to pay a
x amount to see the game and when the
the parents were able to go back to the
field he told me that he came and he
looked for the cameraman because he knew
that
they're supposed to be a cameraman and
then they explain no it's not a
cameraman it's just this system upstairs
and this for us means that we did a good
job we don't
now look to do like we are not looking
to do a
super bowl production with the the all
the the
40 cameras with super slo-mo we want to
give as
i always said we are giving the bread
and butter of the
sport television not the cherry on the
on the cake
i i think that's amazing and i can
honestly see already the reaction of
human nature feeling like a friar
that what do you mean that it's just a
technology actually
exactly this he said wow that mccabe tel
aviv did a very good uh
choice not to tell the parents because
if they if the parents would know
they would start saying ah we don't want
to pay because it's automatically but
you know exactly even automatically
you have people developing we have
people building but
if you bring a person into one it's
amazing yeah it's also and it happened
in in a small maybe a
field in the capital of but it also
happened in
in 15 others 15 000 other location in
the world
in in i think around
8 000 high schools around
a leagues across the world it can be
from we support
14 different sports so it can be a
field hockey a la crosse a
a rugby any type of sport you can
imagine they play in in a field
we there and we we cover this
do you do you predict that you know if
we look a few years down the line then
all the sports games also the nba and
the nfl they'll all be automated through
technology and no cameraman
just just physical just the devices
no i think that for this
the premium sport i i don't think there
is enough
initiative to to make it automatically
because the requirements are quite high
and the
and the scale is not big so where are
the
autonomous important when you can you
have a huge scale
so if you can now reduce the price it
will affect
it's a huge effect uh so and then it
become enabler
but for the so you will you will have
maybe
portion of it automate automated but at
the end
i don't believe that the the super the
the nba the the
champion league this type will be
automated but i do think that
uh and i see it already that the
automation will go away
higher and higher okay so now we have
for example a baseball system that
already have two angles and we have
switching between the angles
we will introduce replays we will
introduce other aspects so at the end
we take all the build blocks of
production and once we cannot
we can automate it we push it into
automatic production and this is
happened both in different sports we
cover
different we also cover not only the
sport
and or not only the live stream but we
also expect
take out the higher the highlight moment
and generate a highlight clip in in some
of the sports like in basketball we not
we can also
give a personal highlight for the kids
that made
the the basket so when the game ends you
can we can generate a clip for number
three and
and send it to his parents so imagine
how fully automatic
so imagine how that's amazing so so it
will become
it will it make the sport much more
personalized
make the the parents and the kids they
enjoy together
and it's fun a lot of fun
so how many games have you streamed so
far
actually uh on july we are going to have
the
1 million
event 1 million game event it's going to
be a
quite a nice event we are running um
but it's amazing the number is amazing
well by far the
the biggest sport platform content
provider today in the world
uh wow much bigger than this piano and
all the
the the big guys but because if you
count them by the hour of production
of course if you count them by the
eyeballs
it's a different story because you can
have a an nba fight
a super bowl one game of super bowl can
be a
like like of course i don't know how
many but if you count by
processing our production hour we are by
far the biggest one
that is really really cool it's amazing
it's a huge machine i see it always i'm
i'm very technician so everything i
imagine is a machine so
so this is a a huge machine that is
has their spread all over the world with
a very back a
huge back-end in the cloud that run
anything automatically
because i i always explain eventually
when you have our system in the venue
and you have a game tomorrow
it's as easy as an outlet appointment
you say tomorrow between four to six i
have a basketball game
between this team and this team submit
and that's all you forget about it
all the things happen automatically
including a graphics including the
the vod live vod notification to the
parents
uh live streaming everything
automatically
no and honestly gal it's and i think you
you're touching us it's a data game
beyond just the
beyond just the footage and the live
streaming this ability to then
personalize and then make and then
extract and then you work in data you
you've done that in sports view
uh you know the importance of you know
of following and being able to
to identify specific players and
specific trends and
and you know i can only imagine let's
say out of the million games let's say a
quarter of them are soccer
and being able to then you know like
even
for fun measure statistics about how
soccer games are run
and how you know tall versus short fast
versus slow
it i think there's there's going to be
some really really interesting case
studies that
you know i as a data scientist can just
get excited thinking what i would want
to do with this data
and so that's very very good what is the
next um
the next step in in in this field
in sports tech so first of all i mean
it's not like we cover i mean we have as
i said we have a amazing amount of
games and actually we are from this 90
to 90 prince 19 99 percent i'm talking
about
we cover uh barely few percentage so so
i think that yeah
still the challenge is still go be
everywhere so
so yeah i think uh we are talking about
maybe
it's it's quite amazing every time in
every sport
when you say it's like the most niche
spot when you go
down in the in the from the professional
to the third fourth league
it's amazing the amount of game they are
played and
the most amazing i think is the used
market in the us
it's it's it's like a a religious
the the way that they treat it is like
religious and and we're now introducing
a
a product which is for this market and
we see that that it
has like a huge potential to be like
a multiplier of what we do now
uh and this is definitely our
first challenge to to to be there
everywhere with all the level from the
ten years that are playing that is
playing baseball
in in and and one of the father is the
coach still can use us
he can take a a gopro and put it and get
a full production of the game out of it
and uh till they in israel you have
the the uh men's the second team
in second leagues the youth league
they're going to be
also other leagues that covered so so
it's quite amazing that they spread and
the different
different levels it cover
i i think that's exactly it you know
when we're talking about that one
percent
the the the lower you go in the level
the exponentially you have more games
because
at the end most of this is one trend of
the connection between one trend
is really be more do more of what we do
the other is is definitely what you're
talking about data because
once you have all this data all this
video extracting data
first of all of usage and and
build the this use it is amazing and
then also extract data from the
inside of the game it's amazing so this
data
is also something we we already working
on uh
most of it automatically some of it we
have also process of
uh of human intervention that doing
breakdown of games this part of the
services we can give
so it's quite amazing uh
amazing gal thank you so much i
i loved it i i gained so much knowledge
just from
19 short minutes it's it's it it's
mind-boggling to me
how much i can get in in 19 minutes i'm
very thankful
for spending this time with me and i
have three questions not about sports
tech but about you gal
if you're ready for them go ahead
going back to middle school or high
school what was your favorite subject
and i told you before i think it was
technical stuff okay because they i
think
and i think that i'm lucky because i'm
not working i'm
having fun most of the time because this
i'm doing what i like so
i and it really started from the high
school because over there i
also use it so i can you can call me a
gig
go go for it but uh
i'm lucky because i'm doing what i like
amazing and who would serve as an
inspiration for you
some sort of role model um
i would pick maybe the most very naive
answer or common answer but someone like
bill gates would
that took different approach and made an
effect
okay because i i
maybe this is why i use iphone from the
first day it came out but
uh i think it really changed a whole
industry or a whole the way people are
doing things and i think that is what
we're doing pixelate for sports
uh and it require
someone that is a can can insist that
he's
he know what you're doing and even if
people
let him down the first
and what are three words that you would
use to describe yourself
uh so maybe it's connected to what i
said before i
see myself as maker it means that the
if people have ideas i think i know how
to make them
a product a company in both of my
company i
i started when there was nothing and
both of them are a very successful
company
i i take it from the technical side
there are people that
always i make sure they are on my side
or that that are taking it from the
business side which is i think it's
a not exact not the same specialities
but
but take an idea and make it
happen so i think this is a something
very strong i have
it's required maybe this is the second
word to be insist so insistent
i mean you fail and you hear no all the
time and you have people say you
told you all the time why why it will
not be in time
why it's not possible why it's not a
a good idea but if you insist and you
you you can convince them then
you can make it work
and uh the cell world i don't know how
to say it
exactly but to grow people to
to make people grow i think that
when i when i meet the right people i i
love to
make them grow and i love that that to
to take them and and you know educate
them and and give them the the right way
to sort
demand a lot but but
you find out that they give much more
than they thought they can give
and i think this is a i think this is
something i
quite good at
this was amazing i i loved it
best of luck with thank you it thanks a
lot i i'm already
you know starting to it's going to be
crazy and the
you know the potential is unless and
when you're describing the
the you know the religious nature of the
youth leagues in the u.s i
i could i saw it i felt it i i was a
part of it
i'm pretty sure that i also played in
little league at some point you grew up
in the us i i spent a few years there in
elementary school and i played soccer
and i played baseball and i played
basketball in a mormon church
and i know i know what you what you're
talking about you know and
i know that we have a lot to make a big
office in the u.s
and some of the parents there are
exactly how the parents
we we aim for so sometimes they can take
the whole family
fly to another place have a weekend in
hotel
just because the 10 years kid had a
tournament
in baseball that is the most boring
thing in theirs
but it's it's i cannot imagine in israel
i'm
doing well good thing that the us market
has more than 300 million
people and israel has nine million so
yeah i think you're in the right place
but gal thank you very very much and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you for
your time
you